for generations we imagined that the
real problem with our infrastructure in
this country was that the roads had
potholes and the bridges were falling
apart
it was pete butterjudge of mckinsey and
co one of the first note no the real
problem with our roads and our bridges
in this country is the racist
here he was in november i'm still
surprised that some people were
surprised when i pointed to the fact
that
if
a highway was built for the purpose of
dividing a white in a black neighborhood
or if an underpass was constructed such
that a bus carrying mostly black and
puerto rican kids
to a beach or it would have been in new
york was was designed uh too low for it
to pass by but that obviously reflects
racism that went into those design
choices
racist bridges now we wanted to hear
more from pete butterjudge he's the
transportation secretary now he's
breastfeeding today so he couldn't join
us but we did want to know what his
record on infrastructure was while mayor
of south bend indiana well there's a
website called real news michiana and it
turns out according to their reporting
what a judge does not a very good track
record when it comes to fixing roads his
so-called keystone traffic initiative
that he put into place as mayor of south
bend reportedly led to the death of an
eleven-year-old boy that initiative
deactivated a non-essential traffic
light and the boy was struck by a truck
casey hendrickson is the host of the
burning truth in south bend indiana and
we're happy to have him join us tonight
casey thanks so much for coming on and i
wish we talked to you earlier before joe
biden made this guy in charge of all of
our infrastructure but what kind of a
job did he do running the infrastructure
of south bend
well first of all i would like to say
that we're not going to apologize for
him because i tried to warn everybody
about this when he was being considered
for ambassador to china that made sense
tucker but when he was made the
transportation secretary i think we
laughed collectively in my studio for
about an hour because he has zero
success in infrastructure planning in
south bend at all everything he touched
that dealt with transportation was a
miserable failure including smart
streets which got tristan killed and he
was warned about that he was told that
there was serious issues with there
being no lights and people going to that
bus depot at seven in the morning it
doesn't get light until around eight
o'clock in south bend in the winter time
so you can't see children crossing the
street and people have been hit at these
roundabouts especially in front of the
hospital for a long time and this is
supposed to be the pedestrian friendly
revamping of downtown south bend
so look this is a news show so we want
both sides we want to be fair so i just
have to ask you the question
did he make the roads less racist though
he obviously made them more dangerous
but did they become more equity oriented
as mayor
i suppose that's a great question he's
increased people's commute by about 13
minutes or so
and i would say he probably made it more
racist considering the demographics
surrounding downtown south bend tucker
because what he did is he effectively
increased response time from first
responders and there's some high crime
areas around there that would primarily
affect minorities in south bend and he's
actually made it a lot worse for them to
get aid from first responders than
before
wait you're telling me that a guy from
mckinsey spends all his time yammering
about how much he loves black people but
then actually hurts them when he has a
chance
figure who knew
it's weird it here's the thing he
tucker pete buddha judge and his his
party have been talking about how south
bend has been systemically racist for as
long as i've been here there hasn't been
a republican mayor since before i was
born the south bend common council is
dominated by democrats if south bend is
a systemically racist city it is because
the democratic party made it that way
you know they used to say that about
montgomery alabama too and they were
right
i sure appreciate your coming on casey
thank you so much and again my apologies
for not talking to you earlier it would
have been helpful thank you i appreciate
the time thank you so much thanks hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else